une petite centaine de formateurs
recruteurs et entreprises du territoire
sont venus échanger leurs idées ce matin
si les yvelines reste un département
dynamique
il n'en demeure pas moins dans les
moyennes nationales avec un taux de
chômage d'environ 10%
en cause notamment la difficulté des
entreprises à trouver des candidats
la plupart des entreprises en tout cas
ce qu'on a constaté aujourd'hui c'est
qu'elles ont des besoins de recrutement
donc d'emploi c'est-à-dire des besoins
réels d'emploi et qu'elles nous ont
beaucoup de difficultés pour trouver les
personnes correspondant à ces emplois
c'est surtout dans les métiers innovants
ou émergents que trouver un
collaborateur reste difficile par
exemple un manque de foi de relier voilà
par exemple ça c'est pas un mot que nos
vents non c'est un métier qu'on regarde
à nouveau face à cela l'agglomération de
saint quentin qui organise cette journée
se focalise sur l'orientation aiguiller
les jeunes vers un métier qui leur plaît
et pour lequel existe une demande réelle
des entreprises
voilà l'étape essentielle pour recréer
de l'emploi
vous ne pouvez pas imposer à des jeunes
d'aller finir général sinon n'ont pas
envie ce n'est pas possible
vous ne pouvez pas dire à un jeune il
faut que tu fasses un bac s
parce que c'est bien pour toi ce n'est
pas possible par contre il faut
également que ce jeune n'a soit
conscient qu'il ya des filières
techniques
cette journée autour de la formation va
permettre deux actions la création d'un
observatoire des métiers émergents et
l'organisation de rendez vous annuel
avec l'ensemble des centres de formation
du territoire objectif prévoir les défis
d'avenir